[Music]
all right let's go to mary in seattle
mary what's up how are we doing
hey that sounds way embarrassing so
hopefully i don't fudge it that much on
this listen
it was super embarrassing and i'm not
even a guy that gets embarrassed and
even i was like yeah i probably
shouldn't have said it like that i
didn't mean to but it just happened is
what it is what are you going to do
right
it just is
hey
so
i love listening to your show it's been
a great
way for me to work through some
past issues and stuff but um thank you
so much constantly yeah no it's awesome
i love it um
you're constantly talking about
practicing desire in sexual
relationships and i wanted to know what
you mean by that like what does that
mean exactly ah very cool okay so
practicing desire
it's i got the language from esther
perel i think just an extraordinary
relationship expert
um she talks about desire is
transitioning from this this path in
relationships that we find ourselves on
which often is is shrouded in shoulds
and have to's and need to's
versus
what do i actually want to do
and so
what happens is you get like let's say
me and my wife we get on a track which
is i need to go do this thing i
have to do this thing i need to i have
to i have to i should have i should have
done this thing
and then suddenly i never asked myself
the question like what do i actually
want here and so what does that look
like in a relationship so tell me about
your relationship
if you want to practice desire is that
the root of this question
yeah i feel like so my husband and i
have been married 15 years
and i think
i would say we're probably i don't think
we're like in the worst spot ever
sexually
but um
we have been at different times in our
marriage
right now i feel like we're doing okay
but when i hear you talk about like
having just this awesome sex life i feel
like that's what i want i don't know how
to get there i feel like we're kind of
mediocre like
we're not struggling but we're not like
awesome like
i want to lean more toward like hey this
is a serious strength in our marriage
where we're just like totally madly in
love i mean we love each other and
i think we have a great relationship in
general but
just
wanting to develop that more to where
it's like
a stronger part of our relationship i
love that thank you for for walking me
through that so
would you be a guinea pig for me on the
show
sure i guess that's why i called right
okay
so you painted a couple of pictures here
and it these often get mushed together
and so i want to make sure that they're
all separate pictures
you said you want to have you've got a
your sex life is fine your marriage is
fine it's good things are good but you
have this
dream of it being
wheels off right
and then you also mushed into there
we want to be i want to be madly in love
and
other expectations on top of that and so
i want to parse out madly in love
which is a hollywood thing
with
a good marriage
and
a really killer sex life
and there's seasons where i'm madly in
love but man i'm so exhausted and tired
i'm in a crazy work season or we've got
young kids or fill in the blank and so
we're madly in love and madly in love
looks like i gotta help wash the bottles
out and i'm helping with the sheets and
the last thing we're do we're just
wiping poop off ourselves at night when
we go to bed from our kids not not from
us hopefully and we're going to bed and
like madly in love looks like we're
doing what we can to survive and then
other seasons madly in love looks like
wheels are off and um
like man we are clicking on all sexual
cylinders right so
what do you
paint me a picture
not a not an overly graphic one like i
painted before the show started what
paint me a picture of
what would it look like
give me a day
of like the dream or what what's your
dream
i think for me like
a lot of times i get into the rut of
like hoods and shoulds and so
for me it would just be like this easy
like yes i totally want you to put the
moves on me i'm loving this instead of
like please just let me go to sleep like
i'm just tired today was a day
so so this is more this is more about
your response to him as opposed to
he's not performing well or he's not the
guy you want him to be right okay no no
no i feel like it's probably more me
just feeling like i mean so we have a
bunch of little kids and
there's times where i've felt i don't
feel it as much lately because we've
been talking more openly i mean we've
always talked openly but i think even
more so lately
where i just have felt like okay
all day long i have people hanging on my
legs and wiping snot on me and begging
me for this and that and at the end of
the day i just don't want to be a need
for anyone else right you don't want
somebody else coming home and
hanging all over you and like meeting me
that sounds i don't know it's just like
so we go in these cycles where i'm just
like i just don't want to be needed
right and
and then where i'm like no i love this
like and when i can finally wrap my head
around mentally like actually i do want
this i really enjoy when we are sexually
intimate like
i actually really enjoy it i but getting
to that mental state of like okay yeah
i'm happy with this
there's been a lot of times where i've
just felt like i am so tired why do i
not get to be in control
in charge of when i get to go to sleep
or
like
it's been kind of um
i don't know that's been like years ago
when we had like when i was pregnant and
had little tiny babies it was just like
ah please leave me alone um and now i
feel like we're kind of coming off of
having little babies and
finding ourselves in like the same
holding pattern just because it's been
what it's been for most of our marriage
and i wanna i wanna figure out how to
flip that to where i'm not just like oh
please don't need me i
like i
want
to enjoy that more yes okay so i hear
this a lot from especially from women
and i don't want to over gender it but i
hear it a lot from women
i'm not super into it until we
start getting into it
and then i remember oh i really like
this
or i heard it said once
um i don't think about sex a lot but
when it starts i really like it and the
more i have it the more i think about it
the more i think about it the more i
want to have it and it kind of it's
self-fulfilling prophecy on one side and
then it rolls off the other side but i
want to push on something you just said
i cannot imagine
like my daughter plays this game called
the sticker game where she grabs your
leg and you have to just walk around the
house and she's attached to your leg
and it's hilarious for like eight
seconds and then it's super not funny at
all and she won't stop
i can't imagine
having little kids all over me all day
long just because they have to eat and
and be carried i can't imagine that and
then can i tell you it is one of my
favorite things in the world
um
just totally rat on your husband here um
i work with big tough guys big fancy
ceos people who make a jillion bucks
like they they think they're gangsters
and they they are they are
but one of my favorite questions to ask
them is how do you initiate sex at your
house you come home you've been
initiating like boardroom stuff here's
how we're going to do this on my company
we're going to do this and you sell that
and you're fired and all that and they
get home and they look at their wives
and they're so insecure and they say
things like
so maybe sexy time tonight right they
don't have like a thing like there's no
way like
how does your husband initiate sex
so
does he give you like that look and
you're like ugh gross stop like how do
you how does he get into it
now um
recently we've been trying to schedule
it which i think has actually been good
for me like i was really
to that idea for a long time and finally
i was like all right we'll try it and i
think it's been good for me to like
kind of alleviate some of the pressure
that i would be like oh is he wanting to
be intimate or can we just go to bed and
like am i going to feel guilty and all
that so that's been like
really great um and you think about it
all day
don't lose that yeah it's true when it's
like oh we're doing this tonight you can
kind of like uh do this tonight then you
think about it and then you kind of go
what's that gonna be like and then
what kind of sex we're gonna have and
then what is right so you start going
down that path anyway which is kind of
awesome but go ahead
yeah so i think that's been really good
but other times if we're just like
cuddling in bed he'll just put his hands
you know like moving his hands on my
body or
um i think we've cut we had some times
where it was like
i felt like the only time we would ever
be physically intimate at all was like
if we were gonna have sex and
that was a few years ago i think we
needed to just hug more and hold hands
more and just kiss just to kiss and
that's been really good too but
sometimes i feel like oh is this loaded
and it like scares me which sounds dumb
i'm not excited
but like it doesn't so here's what's so
important hard to get into no here's
what's so important here's what's so
important
so you
you said it so beautifully and i'm gonna
flip it around you and i want you to
flip it around on you and i want you to
take this with you
you said i just don't want to be needed
anymore at the end of a day
so get that
the question i want you to start asking
yourself is what do you need
and how do you need it
and what would you actually want because
you spend all day responding to other
people to your kids i don't know if you
work but to work stuff and then you feel
like you're playing defense against your
husband like what what what like what
are we doing do i have time i'm tired
but can i fit this in but
and all
at the bottom of all that it's being
sacrificed is
what does mary want what does desire
look like for mary
what would it look like for mary to say
hey
tonight is a hug night
i need lots of hugs
tonight is a
sex night but it starts at 8 a.m i need
some help in the kitchen
so here's here's what i want you to have
in your head
number one
can sex become and this is where the
practice comes in can sex become a place
that you escape to not escape from
and so at the end of an exhausting day
at the end of a hard work week
can it be a place where
all of the expectations roll off all of
the what you just laid out so perfectly
the i don't know is it going to be this
i just want to hold hands can we just
kiss and just go to bed and it uh if i
kiss him then it's going to turn into
this and then oh no i'm doing it i don't
want to i'm tired
can you get rid of all that stuff and
start being super clear with one another
can you say no is that like
at the beginning of the day like when
would you
like how would you actually put that
into practice like i feel like we've
been trying to get more clear when we
decided okay let's start scheduling this
so that is more clear and that has been
super helpful but
at the same time my husband's like well
that's lame if it's like the only time
we can ever be intimate is if we
schedule it like can we never be
spontaneous and i'm like i don't know if
i'm there yet i'm trying
and
i want to be there like i want to be
like oh sure it wasn't on the schedule
but you know what i actually desire you
too and so so so you're you're beating
yourself up right there you're beating
yourself up because
we're not in a movie
and i want you to free yourself from
that
the simple solution to that to what you
the question you just asked me is you go
ahead and put an extra one or an extra
two on your calendar for the week
and you surprise him
and that way you both win it's on your
calendar you know it's coming you can
plan for it all day
and he doesn't know it's coming
and you can say what would it look like
for me
to totally
get after him
and then you start to feel what would
that power feel like what about him
meeting my needs for once
what does that look like
and i'm going to wear what i want to
wear and do this how i want to do this
where i want to do this
and i'm going to stick to kids in front
of a stupid tv screen because i don't
even care does that make sense
it's about you moving to offense and so
that that that thing you just said is
simply about i'm not at a place where i
just think about it at four o'clock in
the afternoon he walks in the door
but i'm gonna already have it on my
calendar
or i'm gonna text him and i'm gonna have
him
meet me in the garage i don't know
whatever works for you guys man right um
i want you to focus on not what is but
what could be and you begin to practice
how do i get myself there
and it may be that you've got two let's
say y'all put two on
on
uh on the calendar each week two days
we're gonna sleep together two days this
week
and you go ahead and put two other ones
just for you you don't tell them about
them and one's in the morning and one's
like on the afternoon sometime or in the
evening whenever
one is hey i'm in the mill cooking
dinner can you come help me in the
bedroom real quick and then all of a
sudden he's like what is happening and
it's gamer
my hunch is
you thinking about that planning that
we'll get that thing to get the train
going down the track for you and if it
doesn't he doesn't know
so you haven't you haven't let him down
that's one of your special stars if that
makes sense
right the second thing i want you all to
do is i want you to get emily nagotsky's
book come as you are i'll link to it in
the show notes it's the single best book
on sex i've ever read in my life it's
written for women
um about their bodies and they were just
left out of the conversation most of
them were
it's a it's a phenomenal book but it's
also really important for men to read
too
and it talks this whole idea about a sex
drive is nonsense it's a it's a series
of
breaks and gas pedals
and it just hear me say this it's about
how do i turn more of the ons on and
more of the offs off
and those things happen 24 hours a day
is 365 they're not about the 45 minutes
we've put on our calendar for for having
sex or for not having sex
it's about how do i create a world
that my wife feels
free and has space
to let her mind go bananas with me as
the at the end of that fantasy
how do i create a world where my husband
feels connected and safe and loved here
at home or whatever words he needs
to where he is ready to party when the
time comes
and so it's about creating an entire new
ecosystem
around a married couple especially folks
who've been married for a while
and here's the last thing i want to pass
along to you
you guys are going to reinvent things
now
and so what we often try to do and you
may have heard me say this we often try
to drag our past remember we were dating
and it just was like this
and then it's like remember we were just
newlyweds and we had no kids we were
having sex at four in the afternoon on a
wednesday
on the kitchen table like where are
those days and what i'll tell you is
we take those days and we compare them
to what we have now and we say oh we're
lacking something we used to have
passion and now we're just old and
boring or we used to be
reckless and rambunctious and now
blah has got to pay the light bill and
let's just watch the office and go to
sleep
and so what i want to tell you is you
can't compare your now to then different
worlds different people different
experiences you got kids everywhere you
got expectations you all look different
everything's different
and
you get to create what
next looks like
and for some people after year 15 that's
when they they're like hey we're gonna
start
doing dress-up week or we're gonna start
what's your craziest fantasies here's a
fun one here's an envelope system it's
called the jandalone erotic envelope
system it's not for sale it's for free
they're
ten envelopes
out of deck a drawer you have at your
house
you take five and he takes five
you each write down one crazy thing you
want to try or it may be boring i want
boring married person sex or i just want
a french kiss for 45 minutes and that's
it hands behind your back sucker or
maybe it's fill in the blank whatever it
is
and
once a month once a week you commit
to we're gonna draw a random envelope
and no matter what we're doing what's in
that envelope or i'll i don't i may not
fully understand what you're asking here
or how this is even physically possible
but i will give it my the best shot like
whatever it is
and
it adds some mystery all day you're like
wonder what's in that stupid envelope
and he's gonna be like oh i hope she
picks this one envelope and you're gonna
be like oh gosh i hope he just picks
this envelope and you're gonna get there
and you're both gonna be into it and
it's going to be awkward and you're
going to be laughing and it's going to
be weird and you know what you're going
to feel like
newlyweds again
you're going to feel like you're dating
again it's going to feel weird and a
little bit ah what are you doing
and that's going to be how you reclaim
and practice intimacy and you may not
even be able to get through them it may
be a disaster and you'll laugh and just
go back to married old boring person
boring old person married sex right
but little things like that that you get
to recreate what this thing looks like
and so what i wanted you to hear me say
is the trapped feeling you have is a
thousand percent valid and real
and it's a thousand percent in your head
and it's a thousand percent something
you can correct for
and
let me leave you with this last thing i
said i only had one more thing one thing
commit to each other to being curious
not judgmental
be curious
when you find one of that random tuesday
at two in the afternoon and you think if
my husband was here i would rip every
shred of clothing he has off his body in
the yard i don't even care be curious
about that moment what about that moment
that day
what about him what about you what is
going on that might be something you can
build into your life
on days he comes home and he's he's like
hey is it time for sexy time and you're
like ah how about i stab you in the face
with
like a fork i'm holding in my hand
take inventory of that don't judge
yourself don't beat yourself up don't
beat him up ask yourself be curious
why do i feel like i want to stop this
guy that i love in the eyeball and i
like sleeping with him like it's not
normal why do i feel like that be
curious about it and then you can begin
to reverse engineer the world that you
actually want versus the one that you're
you're experiencing does that make sense
yeah no i think that sounds great i feel
like just listening to you and giving
it's like giving me hope that like hey
we can do better we can get past the
fact that we've had all these babies and
like been tired for a lot of years and
it's like we can do something different
and i want to so i'm glad for your
advice thank you yes so get that book
we'll link to it in the show notes read
it together
and there's going to be parts where
you're like whoa and there's the other
parts you're like i don't really get
that read it together don't agree with
all of it that's great but it's going to
give you all something to work towards
and then go with the john delaney erotic
envelope system it's free and it's
amazing and it will change everything
mary
man
[Music]
you make me happy for mankind and
womankind you're awesome